PAUL: Hi guys.
I'm Paul Kinlan and I'd
like to introduce Alex
[? Krymovsky, ?]
who is a product-- you're a
product manager, right?
ALEX: Yes, product manager
on the web platform.
PAUL: Cool, on the
web platform.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
And I'm working, well, actually,
we are both working
on the Web Intents project.
Today this is the first of our,
hopefully, biweekly, or
fortnightly, as we say in the
UK at least, series of Web
Intents Wednesdays.
It's not every single
Wednesday.
We want to try and kick start
the community, and kick start,
basically the hype.
What kind of what's
happening inside
the developer community.
What's happening
with the apps.
What's happening with
Web Intents.
And just find a generally
friendly way to actually get
in contact with you, the
developers, building
applications on the web today.
Who are interested
in Web Intents.
Who want to know what
it's all about.
And, yeah, let's go from here.
So, we have a little bit of a
technical snag at the moment.
We wanted to give you a nice
demonstration of what Web
Intents are.
And, show you some
applications.
But, unfortunately, the software
that I'm using,
decided to start working about
three or four minutes before
the presentation.
So, my apologies.
The next time we do this, we'll
give you a better set of
demonstrations, and, hopefully,
show some
applications that all
the developers have
built in the ecosystem.
But in the meantime, we must as
well just get started, and
talk about what Web
Intents are.
Hopefully, Alex will be able
to grill me with all of the
questions that US developers
also my interested with.
ALEX: Yep, so I'll be playing
the role of you, basically, in
this interview, asking him all
the hard questions as far as
to channel what you'd be
asking, hopefully.
PAUL: Cool.
So we also do have
a moderator page.
It's on our Google developer's
live moderator.
So, if you just go to our
YouTube channel and see this
event, you'll be able to
go and ask questions.
We do have a really set of
questions that we're going to
try and ask, answer or ask
answer a little bit later.
But, anyway, we'll start
with an introduction.
So, like many people, you might
have heard a little bit
about Web Intents, but are
not actually quite
sure what it is.
So, Web Intends is basically
a standard, or
not standard, sorry.
Not standard yet.
It's a specification that's
built into Chrome that we are
working on with the W3C at the
moment, to actually help
application developers be
able to integrate their
applications a lot
more easily.
Right now application
developers, if they want to
build an application, I don't
know, that talks to Twitter,
or some other remote kind of
sharing service, you have to
normally do a deep
integration.
You know, the user not only
has to install a piece of
software, whether it's a
bookmarklet, or some other
kind of widget to actually
have the share happen.
And Web Intents is designed to
kind of say, well you could
use to develop but you can't
actually build all these deep
integrations into your
application.
You can't support every single
social network that lives on
the open web today.
But you want to give your users
control, give your users
some flexibility to be able to
choose the services that they
want to use for these actions
across the web.
Now, the interesting thing is
at the Web Intents API is
designed to kind of slightly
dis-intermediate some of the
APR integrations.
You don't have to have a deep
integration to be able talk to
the remote services.
And just before we continue, I'm
just going to move this,
because, it turns out, I
composition cameras very well
for our presentations.
And now, Alex is out
of the shot.
So here we go.
That's a little bit better.
At least it should look like
I'm looking at you, rather
than at some person
behind the screen.
So I apologize.
So, Web Intents is just a simple
APR that allows us to
build applications that talk to
each other way more easily
than it is right now.
We would normally show
a demonstration, but
unfortunately, because the
screen sharing doesn't work.
And It is my machine, and
it's all my fault.
It's not a problem with
the actual software.
We can't shoot a nice little
demonstration.
So, I tell you what.
Should we talk about some
of the news, things--
ALEX: Yeah, let's talk about
what's happened in the last
couple of weeks.
PAUL: Yeah, OK.
Cool.
So in the past couple of weeks
what's kind of happened with
Web Intents.
Well, I think the first and the
biggest thing, for me at
least, was we did a presentation
at Google I/O. It
Is on our YouTube channel at the
moment if you want to go
and check it out.
And actually, there you will
see demonstrations that are
live, that we did on stage,
using the Web Intents API.
So, we do have a presentation.
We also had a really kind of
interesting meeting with W3C,
where I wasn't actually present,
I was on the phone
call at the time, where we were
kind to talking about how
we can basically integrate
further
API's into Web Intents.
I'm going to share the links,
the notes, because the notes
are publicly available, but
not many people read them.
So, just after this presentation
I'm going to
share the notes.
The interesting thing is that
it's interesting to see the
types of APIs that want to
integrate with Web Intents, so
if people want be able to pick
media, or picks contact from
your particular device, so let's
say, it's your phone.
You want to be able to pick
a contact from your phone.
And the best way to do it, well
maybe, not the best of it
right now, but the best way
we're thinking about doing it
is by the Web Intents API.
So you can basically say, you
know, i need to pick a contact
from my address book.
Your address book on your phone
could actually live as
the physical address book, but
it could also be Google
contacts, it could be whatever,
it can have services
support on the web,
that support to be
able to pick contacts.
So that's one of the areas
that we talked about.
And also picking
media as well.
So, the idea is your phone
might have a gallery, you
might have a gallery
of your favorite
photos on the web somewhere.
You know, you should be able
to pick that photo, or any
kind of media from those devices
and actually be able
to manipulate in such
application.
ALEX: I think, the point here
is that Web Intents is not
just one singular API, it's
actually enabler with lots of
other stuff.
PAUL: Yeah.
ALEX: So, people are really
starting to discuss,
especially right now in W3C and
other standards bodies and
groups, how they could use this
plumbing of Web Intents
to connect up applications with
other things, like media
galleries and that
kind of stuff.
PAUL: Yeah, that's the kind
of interesting thing.
We all talk about
sharing data.
You know, to be able to share a
link to a social network is
one of the key APIs.
But that's actually one of
really small facet of what Web
Intents is trying to do.
You know, we want to connect
applications based on an
action, so the user wants
to perform some
action on the web.
They want to edit
an image, right.
Well, they want to kind of
pick a document from some
cloud file storage solution.
They should be generalized
actions by an API, which
hopefully is Web Intents, to be
able to just let you say,
well, my application I need to
pick an image from somewhere
on the web.
It could be on your hard drive,
it could be on your
cloud file storage solution.
We've got some Chrome
extensions, which I'll want to
share out a little bit later,
which let you pick an image
from an individual tab, that's
running inside your browser.
Which is kind of cool, right?
I mean picking an image from
another web page that's
actually inside your browser,
is actually a
pretty complex task.
You find the image, you right
click it, download it
somewhere, and upload it into
another application.
ALEX: I do it all the time.
PAUL: Yeah, I mean, everyone's
got this download's directory
that's just full of--
whoa, I was going to say
a rude word-- rubbish.
it's just full of things,
you know, it's just like
[INAUDIBLE] basically.
You just download it, you never
delete it, you never get
around to, because your
applications aren't
integrated.
So, yeah it's not just share,
it's pick, it's edit, it's the
ability to say, I need to
edit this image just to
remove some red eye.
You have to find an application
that supports
image editing, and you'll be
able to send the data there
and pull it back.
So next week I'll show you--
well, not next week, the next
time we do this in two weeks
time, I'll show you a proper
demonstration about how
old all this hooks up.
And I'll actually show you the
code as well, because it's
actually really simple.
ALEX: It's surprisingly simple
to get this to work.
PAUL: Yeah, so the demo that
we have is on [INAUDIBLE].
It's like twenty lines of code
with four different actions.
ALEX: So you can wait for two
weeks to see the demo, or you
can just check out the I/O
video, which shows off the
demo, more complicated demo
has all [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL: And it also shows a really
cool presentation of--
I say presentation, a picture
of when I prove I invented
Google glass.
Two or three years ago, right.
You have to go check it out.
Just check it out to see what
it's like, because, I think,
it's pretty cool, but
no one believes me.
Cool, so--
ALEX: Shall we do questions?
ALEX: Yeah.
We might as well jump
to the questions.
We have about 10 questions
so far.
ALEX: And just so
you know, again.
The link to submit questions in
the Google Moderator page
is on the plus page.
So, follow that link, submit
some questions and we'll walk
through these.
PAUL: Yeah.
I mean this week is very much
an experimentation week.
We want to hear feedback from
you guys about what you want
to hear, what you want to see,
and just kind of the types of
information that you'd like
to get info, a kind of
bi-weekly round up.
So, feel free to email me.
paulkinlan@googl.com.
I'm very open to share
my email address, so
it's not too bad.
But, yeah, let's jump into
these questions.
So the first question from x is
have you considered cross
Android Web Intents.
Could you enable some interest
in these cases like being able
to directly launch into related
parts of a web app
from a related Android
app and vice versa.
ALEX: I think, and we were just
talking about how there's
interest in W3C in using Web
Intents for all other things
to connect MediaStreams and
that kind of thing.
And I think this is exactly
the same vein, right?
Web Intents is very directly
inspired by Android intents.
They work together relatively
nicely because they are
directly inspired, and you could
imagine all kinds of
really interesting use cases
they are connected to.
So, I think, this is absolutely
a great idea.
It's something really cool
that we'd love to do.
But, right now, we
don't have it.
PAUL: I mean, I right now,
we don't have it.
It's something we or I'm
quite passionate about.
However, we have a really big
problem on the web in the
sense that we can't connect
apps easily, right?
We want to make sure the web
developers and apps on the web
at that moment get great
experience like an
interconnected experience.
ALEX: So we're focusing
on making it
work in Chrome today.
Implementing that spec that's
being discussed in W3C before
we move on to even bigger
and cooler things.
[INAUDIBLE]
Android Intents.
PAUL: I mean people on the W3C
at the moment have been
talking about trying to
integrate with TVs, right.
So, you say I need to play a
video, I need to share a video
with something that
can play a video.
You find Intent, you know the
browser, might be able to
discover a list of devices that
are connected to your
home network by UPnP
discovery.
And send the video straight
out to that remote device,
straight from you web app.
ALEX: The possibilities
are really cool.
There are a lot of really neat
use cases that are made.
Very easy with Web Intents.
A lot of people are looking
and are excited to
build on top of.
PAUL: Yeah, but we just
start now, right?
ALEX: Just start now.
PAUL: Is it right?
We've only been I
think publicly--
we announced it a year ago?
ALEX: I think so.
PAUL: I think about
a year ago.
We've been working on new
implementations like Chrome,
working with standards groups
as well to actually get this
off to a good level before we
can actually start thinking
about integrating externally.
Ah, cool, so I hope that
answered the question.
We also have another
question--
what browsers support
Web Intents?
Ah Chrome.
Chrome definitely supports Web
Intents from stable right
through its Canary.
Obviously, Canary he's got some
of the latest things that
are happening inside the API.
But it is actually on a stable
channel of Chrome.
ALEX: I think one of the
important things to emphasize
here is that this standard Web
Intents, we're hoping one day
will become formal standard.
But we're discussing it's an
active, it's a working draft
right now spec in the W3C.
So although Chrome is the only
one that currently implements
it, we've been laying the
groundwork having discussions
with all the browser vendors
in the standards bodies to
make this something that other
browsers can one day
implement as well.
PAUL: Yeah, I mean there's a
good implantation generally
inside WebKit as well now so,
the theory is that anyone who
implements WebKit could also an
implementation themselves
of Web Intents quite easily.
ALEX: So, although, this is
currently only implemented in
Chrome, [INAUDIBLE], there's
hope other browsers
will pick this up.
I should also too really quickly
that the implantation
we have in Chrome right
now is experimental.
We know this API as developing
it is going through the
specification process as we're
talking to other browser
vendors, some things
might change.
And right now, it's definitely,
we want to get it
out there, so that developers
can start using it, can start
showing off all the cool things
they can do with it.
And help us develop and
evolve the spec.
So--
PAUL: And we have
a shim as well.
Which the shim works in
Internet Explorer 8?
ALEX: Yeah.
PAUL: 8 and above.
Opera, I can't remember
which version.
I know it works in the latest
version of Opera.
It did work in Firefox, I need
to fix a book, because I
introduced Content Security
Policy, which I won't say is a
complete nightmare, but it's
harder to implement than other
kind of APIs at the moment.
ALEX: So, basically, the shim
allows you, although Chrome
implements it currently directly
into the browser, the
shim basically allows you to
instead use the JavaScript, a
little bit of JavaScript
include, that would then sort
of pop separate iFrame to allow
the user to pick which
action they wanted and then
connect to the service.
PAUL: Yeah, the theory is it'll
be binary compatible
with the API.
Obviously, as the API changes,
we might get to the points,
where your JavaScript won't be
able to do exactly what we
want to do, but by then,
hopefully, other browser
vendors will kind of all
use the same API.
OK, so the next question- how do
you-- oh, actually there's
another trick question
jumped up in front.
How do you include the support
for suggestions [INAUDIBLE]
in Web Intents in Chrome?
If not, when will we
see the support?
So, just a bit of background
behind this.
Because we couldn't
show the demo.
Web Intents has got quite a few
little features already
built in, when the Web Intents
implementation inside Chrome
has got discovery
features built
straight into the interface.
And One of those features
is the ability to find
applications that will, say,
have the support to,
say, edit an image.
So, the user says, I
need an application
to edit this image.
We can pop up a list, that
basically says this is the
application that the user
has installed right now.
Being that there are other
applications on the Chrome Web
Store which also supports same
types of functionality,
editing images, picking data
from other services.
So one of the things that people
have asked for is the
ability to, basically, manually
control that list of
suggested services, not
necessary have them come from
the Chrome Web Store.
The reason being, you might
know, for instance, that you
support Twitter, right, and you
want to have that ability
for the user, if they haven't
got it installed, to be able
to install that application,
which might not necessarily
directly come from the
Chrome Web Store.
So the suggestions is
basically a list of
developer-provided suggested
services, that they know
complete the action
and complement
their site very well.
ALEX: So, if you're firing and
intent, and saying that you
are starting an intent, and you
know if your apps already,
that are pretty good matches for
it, you can provide those,
so they could be shown to
the user as suggestions.
PAUL: Yeah, It basically,
it's to solve
the bootstrap problem.
We think we've done a really
good job in Chrome in sense of
providing this set of
applications from
the Chrome Web Store.
But quite often developers
would want to
provide their own list.
So, it's actually onto
the question.
It's not implemented just yet.
I believe, we're still working
on it at the moment.
The reason why it's kind of a
little bit up in the air is
because when we've been talking
to the guys at W3C, we
have to iron out a
couple of things.
But it's something that we want
to support, and we got a
lot of developer feedback.
It's just a matter
of kind of when.
So, if you have any suggestions,
I would suggest
that you kind of just pop some
feedback on the Web Public
Intents group on the W3C,
and again, I'll share
the actual list out.
But there is some active
conversations going on about
the types of features that are
needed by developers to have
this API, to make sure it's of
use to them essentially.
So we'd like to say, we don't
have support for suggestions
just yet, but it should be--
hopefully soon, it all depends
on the W3C instead of
[INAUDIBLE].
ALEX: Just to emphasize, this is
definitely an evolving API.
We're learning as
people use it.
What things are useful,
what things they need.
And so we're listening very
carefully to what you guys,
what your feedback is on this
API, to help put feedback into
this specification process in
implementation in Chrome.
PAUL: Yeah, So, that was
Glen Jones in Brighton.
So, I've noticed we've got a
whole load more of questions
in, today as well.
So, hopefully we'll be
able to answer them.
So, let's have a look.
Have you been doing any work
with NFC being enable to
receive Web Intents from tags?
Android Beam et cetera, seems
like a logical fit.
I think the quite frank
answer is not directly
anything with NFC.
I think there's a couple of
interesting possibilities,
which, I believe, have been
discussed briefly on the
Public Intents group.
Basically being able to kind of
look out for the URLs, the
user might might go to that
applications now can handle.
But, this is just too early on
the the whole specification
the moment.
We want to make sure that we
have a good solid ground to be
able to find applications that
perform definite tasks before
we think too much about trying
to integrate with NFC.
ALEX: There's possibilities,
really cool ideas.
Like NSC is a great idea here.
But we just have a lot of stuff
that we're trying to do.
And so we want to get
to that point.
But right now, we're focusing
on really making sure that's
the core foundation is really
solid, and something people
could build on top of.
PAUL: Cool.
So, yes, I hope, that answered
the question.
You know, it's one of
those things, right.
And then we're tracking this
now, so we should be able to
give you some information
as things change.
So, if we talk about it on the
Intents Group, the W3C, then
we should be able to find a nice
way to actually give you
this information back.
And, so the next question.
In the recent Google I/O 2012
talk you mentioned that the
interface for Web Intents in
Chrome is currently being
redesigned.
When will we get to see it, and
can you talk about it now?
ALEX: Also, one of the coolest
things that I think is really
cool about Chrome is that we do
the vast, vast majority of
the development in the open.
So, if you're using Canary,
you're seeing the very cutting
edge of what's in Chrome.
So already some of this
work has started.
And actually, if we were able to
show the demos, then you'd
see that the UI shifted already
a little bit, and so
we're already starting to make
progress on updating this UI
and making it really,
really smooth.
PAUL: Yeah, I mean, some of the
feedback that we've had,
is that, actually, the user
interface didn't response,
especially for inline intent.
And for those of you who don't
know what inline kind of
intent is, it's the ability
to have like a pop-up that
appears, just over the context
that the user currently has
inside the browser.
So if they say, I'm going to
share a link from a blog, for
instance, you don't want to
necessarily be completely
redirected to another
application like Twitter or
Google+, or these
types of things.
You just want to appear it, like
how it appeared just over
the thing that you want
to share, right?
So the inline intent,
is that same thing.
And this is one of the areas
that we got a lot of feedback
from developers, at
the moment, is
that it looked rough.
Early, early I think is
the way of saying it.
ALEX: And we're definitely
working on
iterating on that design.
And we knew it was rough.
But we wanted to get in it in
the hands of developers, so
that they could start
using it.
PAUL: So, if you go to the
Chrome Canary channel now.
And fire the intent,
that is the share.
demos.webintents.org is a
good place to start--
you'll basically see,
the inline of
user and spaces changed.
So it's got this idea of, again,
constrained dialogue.
The idea being that the intent
picker itself can actually
adapt more freely to the user
interface, to the actual page
that's being displayed.
So the page that you've embeded
is 800 pixels wide,
the actual user interface, the
actual intent display, will
adapt to that 800 pixels.
So, it is being worked on,
and expect more changes.
ALEX: Expect a fair number
of more changes.
We're really working hard to
make this a really tight UI
that's a pleasure
to work with.
PAUL: Yeah, I mean the success
of Web Intents is kind of
generally tied to
user experience.
So just the users need to be
comfortable with what they do
inside the browser.
And we are acutely aware of
this, and we are making
changes the accommodate
for that as well.
So, hopefully, that again, was
Glenn Johns, and he said--
Jen Johnes?
Don't worry about that, I've got
spoonerisms on my brain.
So the next question.
As a user, how can I find
possible varieties for any
given intent?
Is that something third parties
can do to catalog
providing of different
intents?
ALEX: Before you answer that
question, I just want to point
out too, just so just for
people who aren't aware.
When you fire a Web Intent as a
developer, Chrome Web Store,
what we do write down today,
is if the user doesn't have
any Web apps installed that can
handle that intent, then
we show actually a list of
apps that can handle that
intent from the Web Store.
So this is a natural way that
even if you fire an intent,
even if the users don't have
anything installed, they are
going to still find applications
really easily
that can handle that intent.
PAUL: So, yeah that, actually,
pretty much answers part of
the question.
It's completely possible, for,
if the user agent wants to
implement intents, that they
might have their own directory
of intents themselves.
This, actually, brings up an
interesting question about why
we went to the Intents
side, right?
So, for me, right now,
we have to use that
manifest inside Chrome.
So you have a Chrome
applicational extension, which
has, basically, a small piece of
what essentially amounts to
JavaScript inside the manifest
that describes exactly what
your application does.
It says my application can share
links or edit images.
So the interesting thing, just
generally, is that the Chrome
actual manifest itself is
very specific to Chrome.
And when we've been talking
about Web Intents publicly,
generally is, you know, we're
really kind of keen on this
idea of an intent tag.
You know, a very small piece of
HTML that can live inside
applications, web applications,
on the web, that
actually describe the
capabilities of the URL.
What it enables you to do is
things like search engines,
for instance, who come along
and start to understand the
capabilities of the apps,
so that they could offer
suggestions for the user.
If they, for instance, maybe
search on the open web
image-editing applications,
right?
So, it's kind of cool.
And at the same time, it's
because it's a tag
indiscriminable on the open web,
any third party system
could come along, scrape
the contents and
provide that directory.
So I'm not going to say open
intents.org are going to do
this, because we haven't spoken
of this just yet.
But you know, they could go
along and start cataloging the
intents that have been
discovered on the open web,
which can provide extra
directory services,
so you can go in--
ALEX: Yeah, the community here
is really going to be really
key in helping evolve how to
use Web Intents, and how to
catalog which events
are available.
And the internet tag
is really key.
So today we're using the Chrome
Web Store as an natural
directory of stores
of applications
that can handle intents.
But that's the temporary
solution.
We were working in this with
W3C in this standardization
process to find a way for just
normal web pages to be able to
say, hey, I can handle
that intent.
PAUL: Yes, and the application
capabilities should just be
available on the web
just generally.
ALEX: Yeah, absolutely.
There's one other thing I wanted
to say, which is, an
important part about Web
Intents, I think, is Web
Intents is basically the
plumbing that allows you to
connect up to not to know
whether or not they're
connecting up to, and for Chrome
or the browser to help
initiate that connection.
Once you have that, how you talk
over that connection, is
to some extent, up to the
conventions that you're following.
It's just going to be really,
really important for the
community to be actively
involved in helping us define,
as a community, what the right
conventions are to be speaking
over this channel, that Web
Intents allows you to create.
PAUL: Yeah.
So, yeah.
There goes the point we've got,
I think we've defined
five, six, different actions--
the ability to share data,
edit data, pick data from a
service, save out to a remote
service, and view as well.
So they'll be able to say, look,
my application can just
view images, or view videos.
This is just a very small set
of common actions that we
believe are on the open
web right now that
people are kind of using.
But there might be use cases,
for instance, payments, i
think is one, for instance.
And authentication ware.
You know, we haven't
said that we don't
find our intents directly.
We haven't said we don't
find them in like the
webintents.org area, because
this is open and discoverable,
people should just be able to
go and say, well I want to
start experimenting with
the ability to manage
payments on the web.
Fire Intents.
And then applications get
built from there.
But it all depends on great
documentation in the community.
I mean this is what
we found out.
When I first started with this
kind of whole idea is we
wanted the URL for the action
because we can describe
documentation for some of
the best practices.
And, actually, when you speak to
developers, they want even
more documentation, even more
guidance about exactly how
these actions should
be implemented.
And this is one of those things
that we're going to see
on the open web, as well, is
when people start building
their own intents, they'll
want great
documentation as well.
ALEX: Absolutely.
And we definitely want to help
the community be a part of
this, and help them find
how to use Web Intents.
The question was a
really great one.
There's so many use cases
for Web Intents.
I'm so excited to see what the
community is using this for
what, and what kinds of use
cases it wants to enable.
It's really exciting, I think.
PAUL: Yeah, thanks.
I went a little bit far against
that question, so
we'll move to the next
question at least.
How will Web Intents handle
verbs like edit, where the
application design would be
dependent on the context, as
on the file type, e.g. edit an
audio files, it's a song, I
want it to open Garage
Band versus the
general sound in Audacity?
ALEX: It's actually is
a great question.
PAUL: Yeah.
ALEX: So the insight is that
just because you have a
certain file type, you might
still want to open different
types of those files in
different applications, in
different contexts.
So, the example here is I've
got a sound file, it's
technically am MP3, but I want
to open it in Garage Band if
it's a song, versus I want to
open it in Audacity if it's--
PAUL: So, what is Audacity?
ALEX: Audacity, I believe,
is a cool sound editing
application.
PAUL: OK.
ALEX: I've never
used it myself.
I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL: So, we differentiate
between intents on the verb
and the data type
at the moment.
So, right now--
ALEX: I don't know how--
this is the kind of thing that
will be interesting to see how
the community addresses
this use case.
PAUL: I mean it'd be perfectly
possible for someone to do a
new edit intent.
I mean, we don't particularly
want to encourage that,
because, we think,
we've got a very
good generalized solution.
But this, I'll be honest, I
don't know how to quite answer
this right now.
But this is what we're trying
to discuss on the Public
Intents groups on the
webintentsdiscus
s@googlegroups.com.
These are the things that we
want to try to find out,
because if it turns out there's
a compelling need for
editing different types of image
files or different types
of audio files in the context
of an application, then we
might need to provide some
better solution.
I mean, suggestions is one area,
but the developer might
say, look, we want to guide the
user down using Audacity
or Garage Band for one
type of application.
Suggestions looks like it might
handle some of that that
use case, but it's not going
to help filter what
applications you would have
got to install that handle
those types of data types--
ALEX: So, again, Web Intents
is pretty malleable.
So you could use its potential
in the future if the community
as a whole decides, hey the edit
intent isn't expressive
enough, I have a different
kind of edit.
Then, maybe it makes sense to
creative different intent.
We want, definitely, encourage
the community always to keep
the number of intents small.
As the smaller of intents we
have, the more sharing there
can be, the more interaction
the can be among apps.
But every so often there will be
a compelling use case, that
means a new intent.
And as a community, we'll need
to experiment with that and
figure out what's the
right answer.
In this case, one thing to keep
in mind, is that when a
user hits the edit button,
they probably know what
their action is.
Like they know, oh, I want to
edit this song right now.
To some extent, if they see both
Audacity and Garage Band
in their picker, than they
probably know, oh I'm editing
music file, the task I'm
doing right now.
So they might not actually
even need--
ALEX: Yeah, they've
got the choice
themselves to do this, right?
So, they can chose that.
ALEX: That's a great question.
It was from Jay in Boston.
PAUL: So, Glenn Johns from
Brighton, hello again.
What are your first thoughts on
Ian Hickson's proposal for
merging Web Intents with
register to handle APIs with
Mozilla web activities?
ALEX: So, Ian Hickson is the
editor of the HTML5 spec on
[INAUDIBLE], and he recently
posted a proposal that sort of
takes the Web Intents idea and
merges it in with similar
proposal from Mozilla
and other ideas.
So, one of the things to keep
mind about these kinds of
discussions and standards, and
we're trying to collectively
define a new standard, there is
lots of discussion, there's
lots of changing how you
think about things.
And we really are hoping that
something we think [INAUDIBLE]
Web Intents it is really
important.
But it is, of course,
experimental at this point.
And so if, ultimately, as a
community, in the standards
body, if we need to go in
different directions, we are,
of course, open to that.
And so we're looking forward
to working with Ian and
Mozilla and others to really
define this spec
the best it can be.
This very basic functionality.
So that's a very general answer,
but where I'm really
excited to see so much
interaction from other browser
vendors as well, in
this process.
And it really shows that this
is an important problem that
we all want to solve.
It's awesome.
PAUL: The solution is generally
the same as well.
So, the next question, which
is by x, but I think I know
who asked this one.
Mike [? Marnov, ?]
I think.
So, for the sharing intent,
which is webintents.org/share
at the moment, is it enough to
add Web Intents support via
Adthis integration?
So, Adthis is a service that
aggregates the ability to
share your pieces of data
across, I think up to 300
different types of networks.
ALEX: It's a lot.
PAUL: And they've done a lot
hard work to actually
integrate these networks
into a very
common generalized solution.
And the really cool thing is
that they've actually taken
Web Intents on quite early, and
provided an integration in
their that little widget that
you put on the page.
Which will fire an intent.
So there's an issue, which is
the Web Intents logo, which I
gave to them.
Which doesn't well describe
exactly what Web Intents is.
So that's hopefully going
to change soon.
But generally, to this question,
if you've already
gotten Adthis widget on your
page, it makes perfect sense
just to keep it on, because they
aggregate across a whole
lot of different networks.
One of the things that we've
seen with some people that
we've worked with recently is
that when they integrate share
intent they might have a
direct integration with
already, let's say Facebook,
and Twitter.
And what you aren't going to
find is that they have all the
rest of the services.
And all the rest of the services
is generally provided
by Web Intents.
So, that's what we're seeing
at the moment.
I wouldn't get rid of your
Adthis integration at all,
they provide a very valuable
service as well as it's not
just the ability to share with
the different networks.
It's the ability to get metrics,
on like page views,
and also kind of the types of
networks that your data and
your users and viewers
are sharing data to.
ALEX: And ultimately, Adthis
was created to come up to
solve a problem.
A very real problem, that
also Web Intents is
trying to solve as well.
And I think, Adthis adds a lot
of cool functionality, as
well, but Web Intents does
address some of these issues.
So, if you already have
Adthis it's great.
It's really simple to switch
to their Web Intents
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL: And they already provide
support for Web Intents as
well, so it's--
ALEX: But Yeah it's
really cool again.
A lot of people trying to solve
the same basic problems
is showing there's
a real need here.
PAUL: I think the interesting
thing, because Web Intents is
quite generalized, they ability
to share something
normally is links.
But If you look at some
different services, like
Tumbler, for instance,
they share quotes.
You can select a piece
of text, and
share that single quote.
And how that actually works with
the generalized solutions
that isn't Web Intents,
is pretty hard, right.
So, when you look at different
services, and different things
that are going to come
in the future.
You might want to share an
image, you might want to share
a video, like a physical
video file.
You might want to share a
document type, which is very
uncommon, but very specific
to the kind of
workflows that you use.
Whether it's a Word document,
a Google Doc, all these
different types of things.
Actually, providing the widget
based system is pretty hard.
So, we believe, Web Intents
in this case would be--
that's where it comes
into its element.
You can share URL types of
data, with services that
support the same
type of thing.
ALEX: Yeah, so it's not going to
that it is more useful for
other types of use cases that
aren't directly addressed by
Adthis as well.
PAUL: This is a question
from Lynn in Shanghai.
If a website uses JavaScript
shim to register the handler
by intent tags, can Chrome
invoke the handler natively
without the JavaScript shim?
OK so, a little bit of
information about the
JavaScript shim.
So the JavaScript shim is
designed to replicate the
functionality of Web Intents
in browsers that don't
actually support Web
Intents natively.
So right now, that is native
spot inside Chrome.
Chrome has the code available
to actually register the
intent tag natively,
however the
functionality is turned off.
So what it actually means is if
a page detects the intent
tag, it won't do anything.
If the browser detects the
intent tag it won't do
anything at the moment.
This also means the same for
the JavaScript shim because
the JavaScript shim just
delegates functionality
straight to the browser if it
detects a native functionality
is already in place.
So right now, if the browser
detects the shim, in Chrome at
least, it won't do anything.
If it has JavaScript shim,
that's already been detected
and it's inside browser like
Firefox, or Opera, or Internet
Explorer, then they are just
going to be be registered in
the kind of the shims
datastore at
least at the moment.
So, we don't have that bridge,
we don't have that way of
converting users directly from--
you know, if you've
used the shim in Chrome before,
[INAUDIBLE] natively,
to when we get that tech
support down the line.
So we don't have a great answer
of you on that one,
unfortunately.
But that's the state of what
it is at the moment.
I don't know if there is
anything else to add.
I believe, so--
ALEX: Next three.
PAUL: Yeah.
Did we miss any from before?
Sorry about this, I'm not in
presentation mode for the
moderator questions.
So, here we go.
Page load.
ALEX: Did you click on it?
ALEX: I might have
clicked on it.
I didn't click on it.
OK.
So to what extent can OS
native non-browser
applications hook into
Web Intents?
It's a very good question.
Right now, none.
But that doesn't mean that
we can't do this.
If the browser can provide a
hook into its registration
system, then that's something
that could be
supported in future.
It just requires vendor
support and external
application support.
ALEX: This is another
great example.
There's tons of possibilities
for Web Intents in the future.
Right now, we're focusing on
web app to web app, but
there's obviously tons of
opportunity for doing things.
From web app to browser,
browser to web app.
Web app to native app.
Within Android--
PAUL: What about external
devices?
ALEX: There's all kinds of
different connections that Web
Intents could help be
the broker between.
So this is another great example
of something that we
love to do.
And it is a cool idea.
And we aren't looking at it
actively right now, but that
just because we're focusing on
really nailing that basic
functionality of web
app to web app.
PAUL: I believe this is
the last question.
And it's actually for me to
repeat the different types of
intents that we have.
So Wes Short from Shasta
Lake, in California.
Hello, thank you for
your question.
It's one of the six
data intents
you've identified again?
So, basically we've identified
six types of intents, six
actions that users will perform
commonly across the
web that we believe should be
built-in support to the API.
ALEX: I should point out,
built-in does not mean it's
actually specified in
a specification.
It just means that these are
the default actions that we
think user of this API and most
likely want us to build
consensus around.
PAUL: So, the first is share.
The interesting thing about
share is that it's not just
about sharing links, it's about
share any type of data.
So the ability to send some data
from one application to
another to--
like send and image.
So we actually used this at
Google I/O. Our example was
it's really hard to actually
share an image on the web
today to a remote application,
well, like a remote web
application, like Gmail
for instance.
We have mailto.
Mailto Is a protocol
on the web.
So basically, when we need to
send an email, and what
happens, when you click on the
web today is you click mailto,
it'll open up your preferred
application, I believe we've
got it in Gmail support.
And you have encode the data
in a very specific way.
The title to, person to,
the title of the
email, and the body.
But what it neglects to do is
actually, well, most people
want to share not just this
very basic kind of email--
ALEX: Text.
PAUL: Yeah, text.
They want to share images.
They want to share videos
and all the stuff.
They want to share
links as well.
Links that they find
on the web.
And the idea behind the share
intent, is that you can say in
your application, and our
image maker application
example, which we could have
shown today, if it wasn't for
me, has the ability to share
this image out to different
types of networks and support
sharing images very
specifically.
And what this enables you to
do in the future would be,
say, well, I'm want to share out
to Twitter by, say, Imgur,
which is the integration I've
put in as an example.
Images supported challenges to
deliver the data of that image
to that application.
So we have share.
It's not just about
sharing text.
It's about the ability to share
images, the ability to
share videos, any type of
data that you want.
You can be be very specific
about and pass it out.
The next is edit.
The reason why this, I think,
edit is kind of important, and
we need to talk about it a
little bit more, is because
you have data in one
application.
And you want to get in to say
your image manipulation
application.
You may want to put a funny
text or a funny
caption on the image.
Today right now, unless you've
got a very deep integration
with a third party system, the
user has to right click on the
image in the browser, download
it to the desktop, upload to
the image editing application,
change the image inside the
image editing application, then
right click on it to save
it, download it back to the
desktop, and then try to
upload it back into the app.
ALEX: You know, it's funny, Is
when I do that in practice, it
is just what you do.
But when you describe it that
way, that's insane.
PAUL: Yes, yes.
That's crazy.
So, the idea behind edit is you
just say, I need to edit
this image.
And edit, you find the
applications that supports
image editing, sends the data to
it, and then, once the user
has finished editing the data
inside the application, they
can just return that data
back to the corner.
So the data just lives inside
the browser, is transferred
from browser.
Browser [INAUDIBLE] to
browser [INAUDIBLE].
Never really has to switch
the internet if it
doesn't have to.
And then you can edit, and
bring the data back in.
And that's completely different
what we see on the
web today at the moment.
So, edit for me is
really important.
The next, I'm going to skip
one.And that's on
webintents.org documentation
for now, is pick.
The reason why pick is kind of
cool is because we've got
things like Google Drive,
Box, box.net.
Dropbox and box.net,
for instance, these
are all your clouds.
All your files and stuff
are starting to live
in the cloud, right.
You don't want to have one
application, have one direct
integration to the service that
you don't use, right?
So the idea behind the Web
Intents is that you could say,
I want to pick my file, my
image, my document from any of
my cloud file storage solutions
and then bring it
back into my application.
And that's what the
pick intent does.
You pick a file, or pick some
data from some service.
The next is save.
So the complementary service
to pick is save.
So, you want to save an image,
something that you've edited
on the web, or inside
a web application.
Right now, if you're trying to
do a save, you only have to
save to the file system.
You either right click to save
direct, or maybe do some hack
in Chrome to only anchor, to do
a download, and put in the
downloads directory.
It's pretty crazy, right?
And save is designed to say,
well I picked from Google
Drive, for instance, I don't
want to save it to Dropbox.
So the idea is that you can
have these three service
integrated, not necessarily with
each other directly, but
you can pull from one service,
edit the data in another app,
and send it back out.
So pick is to pull data in, and
save is to push data out
that you've just edited,
for instance.
We have also view.
So view is kind of interesting,
right?
Most people don't think of this
on the web, probably,
you're watching a YouTube
video and
watching inside YouTube.
Or you're watching video, or you
might watch inside Vimeo.
But what do is you actually
have a video file that's
either been sent you via email
or it's on your desktop and
you want to view it inside, like
a special kind of video
viewing piece of software.
You're not necessarily going to
upload it to one of these
kind of video services just
to go and view the video.
You might just want to view
inside your web app.
And we don't see many web
applications today which are
just dedicated to viewing
file types.
We just don't see them at
all, I don't think.
And the view intent is
designed to save up.
You know if Chrome detects that
you, for instance, that
you've downloaded a video.
I mean, this functionality
is not there, just yet.
But if Chrome has detected that
you've just downloaded a
video, why not try to view
the video inside the web
application that is
on the web today.
So view, is, I think, is
a pretty important one.
I think it's quite important
for things like Chrome
[INAUDIBLE] as well where
literally all your
applications just
live on the web.
ALEX: But this is a great meta
point too that there are
things that you do today that
are sort of annoying to do,
there are other things
you don't do
today, because you can't.
PAUL: Yes.
ALEX: So Web Intents enables
new types of integrations
between apps that couldn't
exist before.
So, that's one of the reasons
that I guarantee that this
list that we've got here is
going to have things added to
it, as people actually use Web
Intents and realize what the
full potential of this kind
of technology is.
PAUL: Yeah, people have been
talking about things like a
pay intent, for instance, if you
want to buy some goods on
the web, using a preferred
merchant.
Like merchant record.
So, yeah, these things that we
are not even thinking about
properly just yet, which people
can start and develop.
So, I think, view is kind
important as well, I say kind
of, it's very important.
We do actually have view
slightly integrated into
Chrome at the moment.
So if you download an RSS feed
or and Atom feed, you'll be
presented with a list
of services
that can support that.
I think it's only in Canary and
dev, I don't think it's in
stable just yet.
So this is one of those things
once the user interface on the
flow gets a little bit better,
we're going to start seeing
these things roll out
a little bit more.
But, yeah, you can view RSS
feeds and Atom feeds in your
preferred application.
And one of those applications
can actually just be the
browser with their XML view.
And the last one we've
got documents is and
intent called subscribe.
The idea behind this is if
you're on a page, you want to
subscribe to say an RSS feed,
or changes to the state of
that page inside your preferred
application.
So you might not only view an
RSS feed in a specialized
reader or a special view, but
you might have it subscribed
in a different type
of application.
And one of the guys who've
have implemented this is
Message Boy.
I checked it out on the Web
Store at the moment, because
they have the subscribe intent
already built in, which just
basically allows you to say,
look, I'm going to subscribe
to changes in this RSS feed.
And to add this application is
going to do something that is
not normally just like a view.
It's going to aggregate the data
and do things behind the
scenes that normal view
intents wouldn't do.
So, subscribe is actually
kind of interesting.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah, that's it.
They're the six core ones that
we've defined so far.
ALEX: And again, these are
not built into the spec.
It's up to the communities
to find and standardize
themselves around which of
these intents are useful,
which of the action types and
to find new ones, and find
exactly precisely what
they mean and when
they should be used.
ALEX: Yeah and to check these
out today the simplest thing
to do is go to webintents.org
forward slash verb thing.
So it's webintents.org/share
or /edit, /pick.
What happened there is because
we're trying to document best
practices quite concisely is
that we are going put all the
best practices guidance,
example code, of how to
integrate maybe the share
action, or the pick action
into your applications, both
from a client, and a service
point of view.
So if you're a service that
wants to provide data to
clients, you can say, well, I
need to implement the pick, I
need to implement the pick
for my type of data.
How do I go about doing it.
You go to webintents.org/pick
and then we'll try to provide
you with the best guidance
possible--
ALEX: And we're really working
to improve that as well to
make sure that it's useful, has
all the best practices.
It's a place that the community
can work together to
figure out, to define what
the best practices are.
PAUL: Yeap, Cool.
So, I think that's all the
questions that we've had.
We do have a weird question at
the end that just looks like
some random text--
ALEX: Yeah, so won't
answer that one.
PAUL: Well, I can speak
random if you want.
Yeah, so this was our first Web
Intents livestream Hangout.
I'd be really interested to get
the feelers out there to
see what kind of stuff
that you want to
hear us talk about.
ALEX: Absolutely.
PAUL: I don't want to do it
weekly, because we're quite
early on in this
whole process.
I want to aggregate the best
things that happen around the
web, so we can present
them to you.
But also, at the same time, If
you have any kind of things
that you want me to talk about,
get some engineers.
I haven't asked the
engineers yet.
So we've got a couple of
engineers over in America who
are actually working on this
project at the moment.
We can get these in as well,
and talk to them, get some
feedback from you guys.
Hopefully, we'll have a better
Hangout as well, so they can
invite their parties
into it as well.
ALEX: So, everything in Web
Intents is really up to the
community to help figure
out how should we
be doing these Hangouts.
How webintents.org
should work.
How to use this API.
And sort of feeding back in to
make sure we're designing it
in the best possible way.
PAUL: Yeah, so cool.
I think, we're done.
So what I'm going to do as well,
and I encourage everyone
to, well, not everyone to do,
I'm going to share a whole lot
of links, you can share
links if you want.
I'm going to share a whole lot
of links on our Web Intents
Google+ page.
I encourage everyone to try
and follow that, because
that's where our centralized
communication channel, of
pushing out updates
and everything is.
ALEX: Following all this
stuff is hard.
If you try to follow the spec
discussions on W3C, there are
a lot of very smart, very
technical people having very
interesting and complicated
discussions.
And as a web developer, I just
want to summarize it for you.
So Web Intents Google + pages
are a great place to follow in
a more summarized way, easier
to consume way.
To know what's going on.
PAUL: Cool.
So thank you very much
for your questions.
I'll be here again in
two weeks time.
So, thank you very
much and goodbye.
ALEX: Bye.
I'm not sure how we turn off.
So stop streaming.
ALEX: Good bye for real.
PAUL: Good bye.